would you prefer beer or champagne yeah
I get for beer one guy in the audience
that's on there why I give I give a beer
because it's you know it's what I grew
up with and I grew up on action or you
know from farm front from a very young
age from no but there was what everybody
gave don't know if my father didn't do
the washing up he went to the pub and
had a drink you know beer was part of
life still isn't it series Maggie
Thatcher or gratitude now this is a
tricky one for me is it's tricky because
you know in fact you look over here but
I've got to tell you as I said earlier
Greta
humbug is one of the stars of our
generation so I would go I will go for
Greta I will go for Greta I mean he will
never know anyway so that's that is a
good point
no I mean but you should be so proud to
produce this young lady there's not
really not general you asked me a lot of
questions I'm not going to ask you many
questions would you be the king of the
bar or the King on the other dance floor
I would be king of the dance floor
I love that I love that mainly because I
remember that wonderful shake up to
shake about hello with the king of the
dance v he was just wonderful
okay so you have some moves then you
turn in love or many exciting
relationships many exciting
relationships but of course fairly
protonic yeah okay so not it's only love
many times no that's what you missed our
Greek and Latin
yes Greek and Latin yes yes I was
getting this is a good one um I'd
actually go for laughing because
laughing is so memorable are so easy and
explains so much of the way we speak um
you you speak Latin like in daily life
or no but I spent most of my life
learning Greek imagine because this is
something you just learned you never use
it right what do you do use it from time
to time like you know what are you
thinking and you know you you you you
you you you use it to show you us how
superior you are just superior being a
good laughing so you prefer football or
Alaska I give for football but really I
give a rugby football I've got to tell
you I'm not much into football as such
rugby football in my mind would you blow
dry or air dryer here I don't know what
either of that means no dry is when you
have this machine you know so you like a
ton of machine gun drying machine okay
you have a new bathroom perhaps I don't
know I tell you I just put a child on my
date exactly like her okay did this
something you do in your father Parmesan
is this do the towel is something you do
in your family it's a sort of family
thing you know we know I have a child
you know we grew up with tongues yeah
Marmite or parmesan I've got to say to
you
I love Marmite but I think parmesan is
just heaven absolute heaven
yeah yeah you won't have any more now
though after breakfast you baby I have
to
I meant bricks it comes cause you're
that bombing then I mean bricks it is
just what everybody's forgotten about
breaks his life carries on and we're
definitely gonna have parmesan oh well
there may be a little bit of a problem
now getting it from Italy but breaking
into that my point exactly
fox hunting or bird watching I gave her
bird watching I think that is just
superb I saw a Kingfisher on my farm the
other day in the river and that
Kingfisher actually had a fish in its
beak I imagine that you know that's the
moment did you take a picture I didn't
but somebody who was with me did and he
got it true he got the fish in the beak
of the Kingfisher what a moment
your other members tumor sweat or too
much too few I go for sweat blood Sweat
toil and tears
that's what Churchill said I'm not
that's what L for you Blood Sweat toil
and tears that's where we are now by the
way that's where we are now thank you so
much Sally Johnson thank you very much
[Applause]
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe
you